bonjour naoufel brahimi merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
abdelmajid tebboune pose une condition
pour un retour de son ambassadeur à
paris je cite que la france respecte
totalement son pays concrètement ça veut
dire quoi le mot respect qu'est ce qu'il
implique
bonjour déjà le nous reste est fait un
nom aux nombreuses déclarations d'
emmanuel macron bon le mal est fait mais
toujours est il toujours est-il
maintenant on est dans une guerre des
chiffres ce qui est vrai il y a un an
quand darmanin s'est déplacé à alger il
a remis une liste de 98 expulsables
prioritaire
cela a été pris en compte
c'était ensuite il ya eu un deuxième
confinement et l'algérie comme les deux
autres pays du maghreb était en zone en
zone rouge avait pas de vols donc on n'a
pas pu procéder à leur expulsion il y a
eu de fait un moratoire et pendant ce
moratoire le porte parole du
gouvernement annonce la réduction du
nombre des visas par deux sachant que
quasiment pendant deux ans durant la con
des milliers de héros visa donc on
divise 0 par deux mais toujours est-il
avant la pandémie le nombre des visas
accordés n'excédait pas 70 milles c'est
déjà insuffisant et dont la déclaration
du président bonne il fait allusion aux
accords de 68 parce que lors des accords
d'evian il y avait un moratoire jusqu'à
68 on devait réviser certaines
dispositions notamment relatives aux
déplacements entre la france et
l'algérie est dépendant pendant assez
longtemps géré pendant une petite
dizaine d'années la france était en
train de dire à l'algérie vous avez
signé avec la france maintenant la
france et européenne il faut revoir ça
dans un dans un ensemble globalement
européens ce que les algériens refusent
ils disent nous avons signé avec un pays
ensuite il ya eu l'europe il n'y a pas
de rétroactivité
c'est dans ce contexte cela
cette crise a éclaté mais surtout
surtout ce que je pense
les propos violents sévère du président
mc ren s'inscrivent dans une lecture
géopolitique
je m'explique
déjà l'opération barkan s'est redéployée
vers la zone des trois frontières où on
va passer de 3 1500 à 3000 soldats ce
n'est pas grand chose vu l'étendue et la
france avec la mort l'assassinât du
président deby la france a perdu un
allié de taille parce que sans fils
autoproclamé président néo - adoubée par
le président m'a cran qui s'est empressé
de s'envoler à au tchad djamena et ce
près ce jeune président est contestée
par son état-major et dans la suite dans
la déclaration des venelles mc ren où il
dit on va priver
certains des cercles dirigeants des
visas
ça veut dire que la france a perdu
certains de ses alliés qui étaient à
l'intérieur du pouvoir certains de ses
alliés se retrouve en prison les noms
sente reconnu pour être appelé
donc dans cette vision globale la france
perd pied en algérie est plus gênant
elle perd pied dans le sahel donc c'est
dans ce contexte là où ses propos
violents veulent recadrer veulent
rentrer alger beaucoup plus coopérative
vous parlez de de propos violents il ya
donc que cette sortie le 2 octobre dans
le monde emmanuel macron disait que
l'algérie jeu recontextualise parce que
vous avez dit beaucoup de choses
difficiles de toute injure jt comme quoi
le système politico militaire algérien
était à bout de souffle sur le modèle
madjid teboul je cite il a dit hier nous
avons été agressés dans notre chère le
nous c'est qui est ce que c'est la
classe politique parce que c'est l'armée
ou est ce que ce sont les algériens
parce qu'on a eue sur en invité
également là semaine dernière enfin
après qu'a eue
le 2 octobre on a eu
vous le connaissez très certainement le
géopolitologue spécialiste de l'algérie
kader abderrahim
qui disait qu emmanuel macron disait
tout haut ce que les algériens pensaient
tout bas
c'est son point de vue mais je réponds à
votre question qu'on a prise dans la
république dit nous il parle au nom des
algériens ça c'est évident et
d'algériens mais pourtant il ya quand
même eu des milliers et des milliers de
personnes dans la dans la rue avec le
mouvement du irak oui conteste l'image
était bonne et l'armée c'est l'autre
sujet mais dans les propos lundi d'une
ou deux les algériens pour que les
agents ont été agressés dont les propos
du président mc ren il est il il fait un
dennis peron négationnistes et pose une
question
y avait-il une nation algérienne avant
la colonisation ça c'est du
négationnisme
ce sont des propos d'extrême droite et
dans la même lancée il dit le système
politico militaire le système politico
militaire c'est une expression d'extrême
gauche qui a été utilisé pendant la
décennie noire qui renvoie des
islamistes et de pouvoir algérien dos à
dos donc c'est le en même temps il est
propre prise dans ma caen où il part ou
du tient des propos d'extrême droite et
d'extrême gauche et et c'est ça qui est
injurieuse c'est-à-dire nier la négation
de l'état algérien et ensuite quand ils
hébergent à la question sur le respect
total quesque abdelmajid tebboune attend
de la france parce que vous avez évoqué
les chiffres de gérald darmanin
jugé faux pars pars à alger vous avez
donc évoquer la crise des visas mais on
le rappelle il ya un ambassadeur
algérien qui a été rappelé il ya
l'espace aérien qui est fermé comment
revenir à
un apaisement entre paris et alger
l'espace aérien algérien est fermé à
l'aviation militaire française
il faut le préciser et comment revenir
[Musique]
c'est très difficile à dire parce que il
y a une stratégie du président ma
crainte le rappel de l'ambassadeur
d'algérie alger ce n'est pas la première
fois il ya plus d'un an
l'ambassadeur d'algérie à paris a été
rappelé suite à la diffusion d'un
documentaire sur une chaîne publique
française qui a été jugé
insultant à l'égard de l'algérie et
comme par hasard c'est le même auteur de
ce documentaire qui est journaliste au
monde qui est invité le 30 septembre à
l'elysée et qui signe ce papier là donc
il y a un vrai calcul et quand on fait
sa stratégie ce calcul où il n'ya pas de
place au hasard ça tu es irrespectueux
et
j'avais déjà dit que cette stratégie se
montra stratégie d'agression je sais je
pense que l'algérie qui vient de rendre
ses relations avec avec le maroc et on
sait très bien que le 31 octobre il n'y
aura plus de gaz algérien pour le maroc
et cela va léser les entreprises
implantées au maroc notamment françaises
sachant comme dans les accords algéro
marocain sur le gaz le gaz algérien
était fournit 20% walsh rp les prix
mondiaux et ans et on sait qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'entreprises françaises
implantées au maroc
notamment une grande marque de
l'automobile qui est connu et donc tout
cela ce sont des pressions sur l'algérie
et je pense que qu'emmanuel mc ren est
en train de pousser a nullement de
l'algérie merci merci naoufel ben brahim
et un mini d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de l'ouvragé france-algérie 50
ans d'histoires secrètes volume 2 aux
éditions fayard